it was january the 29th
2020. a student at york university
was staying at this hotel with his
mother who was visiting from
china at around 6 p.m he called nhs
one one one he told them they both had a
fever
and a cough the world was watching for
the uk's first
covert 19 case this was it
what has been occupying experts here as
they're trying to prevent the
the spread of this disease they're
looking for all the people that those
individuals will have come into close
contact with it's quite a strange
feeling being back outside
the same hotel one year on and
remembering at that time this was a
disease that still
didn't have a name and it was an
outbreak
that seems still a problem for elsewhere
but now it was here and plans turned
into action
we felt we had to be as transparent as
we could
because this was new um people were
scared they were anxious
not just here on campus but obviously
parents of
students all of our staff in a sense we
were the test case for the uk
the mother and son both chinese
nationals were taken by ambulance to
hull hospital for testing
and then for treatment at the newcastle
royal victoria infirmary
where staff knew just how important
every move was you knew that
this was about containment and
you couldn't afford to put the foot
wrong because at that point in time
you know nobody could have foreseen that
it was going to spread how it did
and you kind of knew if you got anything
wrong god forbid
you know the consequences outside could
be disastrous
the mother and son survived and today
the head of the nhs visited the wards
where they were treated
thanking staff for a year like no other
while those staff have been looking
after those coronavirus patients
there's also been huge innovation in
improvements in the
treatments on offer and now of course
vaccines
and that hasn't happened by accident the
identities of those first patients have
never been revealed but they remain the
first
and second cases of now many millions
in a crisis that started here but spread
everywhere
and remains far from over caterina
fratoxy sky news
in york